la poupée un jouet intemporel mais qui
évolue la poupée animé se démocratise en
france au début des années 60
fabrication en masse et baisse des prix
les poupées animées investissent les
rayons des grands magasins en 1962 la
première a tapé dans l'oeil des français
est une baby doll américaine connaissez
vous la raison de son succès elle adore
embrassés mais elle ne distribue ses
baisers que sur commande mais la même
année
la française caroline lui fait
concurrence et elle elle parle dans les
années 70 la concurrence est rude et
rien n'arrête les concepteurs mais
innovation ne rime pas toujours avec bon
en 1979 le top des ventes au sein du
jouet est un baigneur plutôt crado
bouillie très diluées qui est composé de
bananes écrasées avec une étendue d'eau
assez importante de passe comme à ce
qu'ils puissent la vallée facilement
applicables
au début des années 2000 le baigneur
hyperréaliste bourré de capteurs et de
puces se digitalise quand il est malade
on prend sa température
et quand il pleure on peut lui montrer
son doudou avec les années 2010 la
poupée animé devient interactive est
connecté ce n'est plus un jouet mais une
copine on dialogue avec elle et elle a
réponse à tout qu'est ce que tu veux
pour noël tous ses péchés souhait est
que les parents et les frères fois le
relais en de l'e santé 2010 est toujours
plus sophistiqués la poupée interactif
rend maintenant des airs de maman on
apprend les conseils de santé comme bros
heureusement c'est les dents il faut se
laver les mains comme c'est par exemple
en 2018
12% des jouets vendus étaient des
poupées soit une progression de 7% par
rapport à l'année précédente
[Musique]